und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend ihnen allen die positive Nachricht
zuerst sie sind alle noch da in Sharm el
Sheikh bei der UNO Klimakonferenz obwohl
die heute eigentlich zu Ende sein sollte
jetzt geht es in die Verlängerung denn
und das ist die schlechte Nachricht es
gibt bislang keine Einigung weder bei
der Frage wie die Begrenzung der
Erderwärmung auf 1,5 Grad noch irgendwie
in Reichweite zu halten wäre noch bei
der Frage wie ärmere Staaten von
reicheren für Klimaschäden entschädigt
werden können seit knapp zwei Wochen
sitzen fast 40.000 Teilnehmerinnen und
Teilnehmer in Ägypten bei einander
und haben viel geredet und jetzt hat
eine junge klimaaktivistin aus Ghana
genug Nacke Yard dramani sum ist 10
Jahre alt und nimmt ihren ganzen Mut
zusammen
this simple Coaching und der tebo auf
dies feiern
und man kann die PS back you
sie bekommt Standing Ovations der
versammelten Welt im Raum aber Applaus
allein wird nicht reichen
Winnie Hischer beobachtet die Konferenz
für uns um herauszufinden wo wir stehen
wie nie und was noch möglich sein könnte
vielleicht erstmal einer
organisatorische Frage es gibt ja
berichte dass diese diversen
Vereinbarungen schlecht vorbereitet und
koordiniert werden also dass das reine
Handwerk nicht stimmt was ist da dran
also die Veteranen und Veteranen dieser
Klimakonferenzen sagen dass diese
Konferenz die ist die in den 30 Jahren
die am schlechtesten organisiert war das
liegt vor allen Dingen an der
konferenzleitung ja hat es in den
vergangenen Tagen immer nur so eine Art
Stichwort Zettel wie Einkaufsliste
gegeben man hatte quasi ein bisschen im
Vakuum verhandelt weil kein Text Entwurf
vorlag und erst heute morgen kam dann
der Entwurf für das Abschlussdokument
was absolut unüblich ist das kommt uns
Tage vorher es hat auch an einigen ganz
praktischen Sachen gehabt wie
verhandlungsserie die doppelt gebucht
waren unterstanden Diplomaten dann
draußen vier Stunden also die einen
sagen die Ägypter konnten es nicht
besser andere sagen sie wollten es nicht
besser und dieser Eindruck der kann
jetzt eigentlich nur noch weggemacht
werden indem man hier zu einem guten
Abschluss kommt ja tragisch das ist
schon daran gescheitert dass diese
Konferenz das 1,5 Grad Ziel erreichen
hilft das war ja vorher schon mehr als
fraglich was ist denn inhaltlich aktuell
jetzt der größte Knackpunkt
das große Thema bleibt das Thema
Klimaschäden die EU will ja dass die
Chinesen dazu verpflichtet werden in
diesen Topf in diesen Geldtopf
einzuzahlen um diese Länder zu entlasten
die durch Klimaschäden schon betroffen
sind und nicht Chinesen sagen wir machen
das nicht sie fühlen sich provoziert
durch diese Forderung der EU denn sie
müssen in diesem Topf einzahlen ohne
selbst was entnehmen zu können und sie
definieren sicher selbst als
Entwicklungsland das ist einfach die
Frage dieser Nacht an der hängt alles
und wir nehmen anders ja auch die ganze
Nacht darüber verhandelt wird jetzt sagt
die deutsche Außenministerin heute
besser kein Ergebnis als Rückschritte
auf der Konferenz heißt das ein
komplettes scheitern ist auch nicht
ausgeschlossen
das sagen viele hier weil natürlich an
diesem Thema Klimaschäden auch alle
anderen Themen dieser konferenzing also
auch das wichtige Thema CO2-Reduktion
kann eigentlich erst angegangen werden
wenn dieses Schäden Klima abgeräumt ist
und deshalb sagen manche ganz
selbstbewusst hier manche Staaten wir
unterschreiben lieber gar nichts als
dass wir was Schlechtes unterschreiben
das soll natürlich auch den
Verhandlungsdruck noch mal erhöhen und
natürlich ist auch das Spiel schon im
Gange wer hier am Ende den schwarzen
Peter hätte sollte es wirklich scheitern
und dann will ich noch ein sehr
wichtiges anderes Thema das mit
Klimaschutz gar nicht zu tun hat es ist
die schlimme Menschenrechtslage beim
Gastgeber gibten inwieweit
beeinträchtigt dass die gesamte
Konferenz
ja die Ägypter haben versucht das Thema
zu trennen wir haben hier immer gesagt
bitte konzentrieren Sie sich auf die
Verhandlung wir reden hier über
Klimapolitik und nicht über
Menschenrechte und dem ist natürlich auf
verschiedenen Ebenen nicht nachgekommen
worden die deutsche Bundesregierung hat
das angesprochen hat die Freilassung von
politisch Gefangenen gefordert sie hat
auch zugelassen dass sie am deutschen
Pavillon ägyptische
Menschenrechtsgruppen haben sich zeigen
können die sonst kaum Öffentlichkeit
haben wir hatten Probleme hier das Thema
sage ich mal ins Programm zu bringen
weil die Aktivistin von den bewussten
dass sie belauscht dass sie beobachtet
werden einfach Angst hat mit uns zu
sprechen oder auch am Wochenende
schlicht nicht ausreisen können und das
sind Menschen die kommen aus Mexiko oder
aus Israel und kommen nicht aus Ägypten
die in Ägypten die sagen natürlich
vergessen uns nicht wenn ihr 40.000
jetzt morgen übermorgen am Montag
abreißt dieses Thema hat wirklich die
ganze Konferenz immer überschattet und
viele haben gemerkt wie wichtig ist ist
dass man in Deutschland zum Beispiel für
das Thema Klimaschutz frei auf die
Straße gehen kann also eine automatische
Lage wenn man so will auf ganz vielen
Ebenen wie eine herzlichen Dank live aus
Sharm el Sheikh
und damit nach Deutschland wo wir alle
auf einen traditionelles Ritual gucken
dass diesmal besonders im Mittelpunkt
steht einfach weil so ziemlich alles in
diesem Land gerade teurer wird die
tarifpartnerschaft ist seit über 100
Jahren eingeübt Gewerkschaften und
Arbeitgeber sitzen zusammen falschen
streiten und sagen am Ende puh das war
hart wir sind bis an die Schmerzgrenze
gegangen und wir haben letztlich
gewonnen zur Tradition gehört auch dass
das beide jeweils von sich behaupten im
Brustton der Überzeugung auch diesmal wo
es um fast vier Millionen Beschäftigte
in der Metall und Elektroindustrie ging
aber eben auch um die Frage reicht der
Abschluss um die steigenden Preise
aufzufangen oder führt er umgekehrt
sogar zu noch höheren Preisen an die
Linke hat Details
der Stahl glüht der mit sie ihn in neue
Formen bringen können die Firma bew im
schwäbischen Ort Rosengarten fertigt
unter anderem Autoteile man sieht
förmlich die Energie die es braucht die
dafür steigenden Kosten in 2022
herausfordernd
die Verhandlungen mit den Kunden zur
Weitergabe dieser Energiekosten war sehr
sehr und ja jetzt nachdem man da
vielleicht die ein oder andere
vernünftige Lösung gefunden hat geht es
jetzt wieder von vorne los die
Weitergabe der Personalkosten in der
Metall und Elektroindustrie gibt es
prozentuale Lohnerhöhungen im Juni
nächsten Jahres um 5,2 %. und nochmal
3,3 im Mai 2024 3000 € Einmalzahlung
kommen dazu die vom Bund steuerfrei
gestellte inflationsprämie zahlbar bis
zum Vertragsende in 24 Monaten es war
ein sehr Ringen wir haben heute die
Verhandlungen zum Abschluss gebracht
obwohl es zwischendurch mal ganz anders
aussehen wir sind aber alle unsere
Verantwortung gerecht geworden das
beinhaltet dass der Abschluss von heute
Nacht in Ludwigsburg die Inflation also
den Kaufkraft Verlust nur zum Teil
ausgleicht beobachten
wirtschaftsforscherinnen das reflektiert
natürlich auch dass wir als Land ärmer
geworden sind an der Stelle müssen
sowohl die Beschäftigten wie auch die
Arbeitgeber sich entgegenkommen und
irgendwo auch die erhöhten Kosten durch
die Energiekosten sich teilen aber
trotzdem steigen die Löhne die IG Metall
sieht darin auch ein Mittel gegen die
Drohne Rezession mehr Geld mehr Konsum
mehr Wirtschaftsleistung so die
Gewerkschaft
das ist ein guter Abschluss gute
abschlussweise genau dorthin zielt wo es
notwendig dass der private Konsum
gestärkt wird angesichts der
Teuerungsrate dass wir die mögliche
Rezessionsgefahr damit deutlich
schneller dabei ist die Erhöhung der
Löhne aus Sicht der
wirtschaftsforscherinnen gut dosiert
zusammen mit staatlichen
entlastungsplänen ergeben sich ein gutes
Paket das den Menschen Sicherheit bieten
können die große Sorge war ja dass bei
Tariferhöhungen es einen
zweitrundeneffekt gibt das heißt die
Kosten steigen für die Unternehmen sie
müssen das zu Preiserhöhungen
weitergeben und das feiert die Inflation
aufs Neue das wird jetzt vermieden weil
es eine Einmalzahlung gibt und die
Tariferhöhung an sich nicht so hoch
ausfällt damit wird auch der
zweitrundeneffekt geringer
der Abschluss um 3 Uhr morgens zeigt
auch in der Nacht kann man über seinen
Schatten springen und Kompromisse finden
wir bleiben noch beim Thema es gibt die
Unternehmen die ganz gut durch die Krise
kommen es gibt die die sich gerade jetzt
dumm und dämlich verdienen und es gibt
die die massiv unter Druck geraten frei
nach dem Motto das Geld ist nicht weg es
hat nur jemand anderes die ganze Woche
lang gucken wir hier im ZDF auf die
vielen Facetten dieser Energiekrise mit
einem Themenschwerpunkt in der
ostdeutschen Wirtschaft sind die
Unternehmen durchschnittlich kleiner
haben weniger Rücklagen kein einziger
DAX-Konzern sitzt im Osten Andreas Weise
zeigt jetzt eine Branche die zudem
besonders viel Energie braucht auch
jetzt
Leuna südlich von Halle Herz der
chemischen Industrie in Sachsen-Anhalt
einer der modernsten komplexe der Welt
doch Gas Dampf oder Strom wird hier
immer noch viel benötigt
domo einem der Unternehmen im Chemiepark
steckt der energiepreisschock vom Sommer
noch tief in den Knochen
Hoffnungsschimmer der energiepreisdeckel
wir glauben dass wir mit einem
entsprechenden energiepreisdeckel und
den dann anziehenden Mengen weil das
Vertrauen in der Wirtschaft
wiederhergestellt wird dass wir diesen
Winter gut überstehen
Hauptprodukt von domo hier in Leuna ein
Granulat Basis für Plastikteile der
Autoindustrie oder für Folien der
Lebensmittelbranche statt täglich 3000
Tonnen ist die Produktion jetzt auf die
Hälfte heruntergefahren und so sorgen
sich hier viele um einen lange sicher
geglaubten Arbeitsplatz
natürlich die Situation dass wir jetzt
Kurzarbeit haben dass wir nicht wissen
wie es aktuell weitergeht und ja das
betrübt doch die Stimmung in den
Belegschaft die Verknüpfungen im
Chemiepark sind zu komplex wie die
Rohrleitungssysteme alle hängen
irgendwie voneinander abliefern eigenen
Leben Produkte als Grundstoffe für
andere bei infrainer als Betreiber
laufen alle Fäden zusammen viel Erdgas
konnte schon durch andere Energieträger
ersetzt werden
wir haben allein im ersten Halbjahr
ungefähr 30% weniger erdgasverbraucht
als im Vergleichszeitraum des Vorjahres
jetzt sieht man das weitere Einsparungen
realisiert werden die allerdings mit
produktionsreduzierungen einhergehen und
das ist natürlich problematisch denn das
bringt die Unternehmen in
wirtschaftliche Probleme
Einsparungen alternative Energiequellen
preisdeckel all das steht für die
Hoffnung dass es hier gut weitergehen
kann und Energie Knappheit sieht der
zuständige Landesminister Sachsen-Anhalt
für diesen dahinter nicht wir haben noch
im Sommer größte Sorge gehabt ob es
gelingt unsere eigenen Speicher zu
füllen ob es gelingt im hohen Maße
Gaslieferungen zu substituieren sei es
aus anderen Ländern sei es durch LNG das
ist jetzt gelungen das ersetzt noch
nicht in vollem Umfang das was mal aus
Russland hierhin befördert wurde aber es
zeigt uns dass wir in sehr sehr
schnellen Schritten vieles erreichen
können und so schauen viele schon auf
den Winter 23 24 wie es dann werden
könnte für Wirtschaftsforscher ist klar
die Politik setzt den Rahmen aber vor
allem die Unternehmen sind gefordert wir
wissen dass Energie langfristig teurer
wird das heißt wir brauchen alternative
Geschäftsmodelle die auch entweder bei
hohen Energiekosten funktionieren oder
die auf Substitutionen setzen die Zeit
der billigen Energie ist vorerst vorbei
die Unternehmen müssen sich neu
aufstellen
ein Unternehmen bei dem nicht die
Energiepreise sondern die verstörende
Energie des neuen Eigentümers schwer zu
schaffen macht sitzt in San Francisco
und hat erstmal zugesperrt die Twitter
Unternehmenszentrale bleibt bis Montag
dicht und wer danach noch reinkommt ist
unklar Elon Musk der reichste Mann der
Welt hatte den Kurznachrichtendienst ja
für 44 Milliarden Dollar gekauft und
danach die Hälfte der Belegschaft
gefeuert jetzt will offenbar auch ein
Großteil der anderen Hälfte nicht mehr
bleiben Twitter blutet aus manche
Ex-Mitarbeiter sagen voraus dass die
gesamte Plattform in Kürze
zusammenbrechen wird die Ausfälle häufen
sich schon und es gibt offenbar
niemanden mehr der eingreift Claudia
Bates
ein dramatischer Abend bei Twitter der
darin gipfelt dass Elon Musk am
Hauptquartier seiner eigenen Firma in
einer Videoinstallation beschimpft wird
als größenwahnsinniger wertloser
Milliardär als mittelmäßiger kindmann
und nerviger Pickel
gerade war auch pleitebaby-sichtbar die
Firma geht zugrunde
Endzeitstimmung auch bei den Usern viele
glauben Twitter würde die Nacht nicht
überleben und verabschieden sich heilige
Scheiße Twitter crasht und brennt ja
schneller als ein Tesla ich liebe euch
twitter-familie
Elon Musk hatte die Mitarbeiter
ultimativ aufgefordert extreme
Arbeitsbedingungen zu akzeptieren oder
kurzfristig zu gehen hunderte verließen
daraufhin gestern das Unternehmen und
wurden buchstäblich ausgeschlossen der
direkte Weg in die Pleite
wir sehen hier gerade dieses Crescendo
aber letztlich wird sich das alles
wieder abkühlen
twitter ist als Marke einzigartig und
daher werden sowohl die Werbetreibenden
als auch die Kunden mit ihren Inhalten
wieder zurückkommen
44 Milliarden Dollar hat Musk gezahlt
und seitdem geht es runter und drüber
die Hälfte der Mitarbeiter hat er
bereits entlassen darunter das
Top-Management das neue Bezahlmodell
führt zu unzähligen Fake Accounts ein
vermeintlicher George Bush vermisst ist
Iraker zu töten ein vermeintlicher Toni
Blair stimmt zu das Pharmaunternehmen
elai Lilly sagt angeblich Insulin sei
jetzt umsonst woraufhin der Aktienkurs
abrauscht viele Firmen stellen sofort
Ihre Werbung auf Twitter ein laut mask
selbst verbrennt Twitter pro Tag 4
Millionen Dollar
dennoch halten manche gerade dessen
brachiale Strategien für sein
Erfolgsmodell
wir sind einfach nicht gewöhnt das
Wirtschaftsbosse ein solches Tempo
vorlegen so transparent sind wie er am
Ende ist es aber eher genial als
chaotisch weil nach meiner Auffassung
die Schritte die er unternimmt im Großen
und Ganzen die richtigen Schritte sind
um das Netzwerk in Ordnung zu bringen
denn Twitter war fast noch nie
profitabel und Maskat Durchhaltevermögen
wie seine Firmen Tesla und SpaceX
beweisen gleichzeitig vernachlässigt er
diese Firmen momentan zugunsten von
Twitter überhebt er sich
man kann seine unglaublichen
Errungenschaften nicht leugnen aber
jetzt leitet er drei Firmen die
Vorstellung dass es einen super Menschen
gibt nach meiner Erfahrung die diese
Vorstellung nie auf
als Chief Twitch bezeichnete sich mask
was Chef Twitterer heißen kann aber auch
oberdepp die nächsten Wochen bei Twitter
werden zeigen welche Bezeichnung
zutrifft
[Musik]
vom Unternehmen selbst kein Kommentar
auch in der Twitter Pressestelle gehen
offenbar langsam die Lichter aus aus
journalistischer Sicht wäre das Aus für
Twitter übrigens ein riesiger Verlust
keine andere Plattform bietet gerade
Reporterinnen und Reportern ein solches
Netzwerk über Kontinente hinweg
so die Nachrichtenübersicht jetzt an
diesem Freitag von dir Hanna wegen der
hohen Energiepreise sollen auch
Studierende und Fachschüler in
Deutschland entlastet werden das hat das
Bundeskabinett heute beschlossen es geht
um eine Einmalzahlung von 200 Euro offen
ist allerdings wann das Geld genau
ausgezahlt werden kann ebenfalls
gebilligt wurden zusätzliche Mittel für
den Nahverkehr für Bus und Bahn soll es
jährlich eine Milliarde Euro zusätzlich
geben
ein weiteres Thema im Kabinett die
Bundesregierung will die Rechte von
queeren Menschen stärken und hat dazu
einen Aktionsplan beschlossen dabei geht
es unter anderem um die rechtliche
Anerkennung von sogenannten
Regenbogenfamilien zudem soll das
Transsexuellengesetz abgeschafft und
durch ein selbstbestimmungsgesetz
ersetzt werden dieser Schritt soll die
Änderung von Vornamen und Geschlecht
beim Standesamt vereinfachen des
Weiteren ist ein Diskriminierungsverbot
wegen sexueller Identität direkt im
Grundgesetz geplant
gemeinsam besser gegen russische
Desinformation Vorgehen das ist eines
der Ziele die sich die
innenministerinnen und Minister der G7
gesetzt haben bei ihrem Treffen im
mittelalterlichen Kloster Eberbach bei
Wiesbaden außerdem hätten während der
corona-pandemie Extremismus und
Terrorismus zugenommen
bundesinnenministerin ferser sagte dass
die G7 den Kampf gegen diese Entwicklung
weiter vertiefen wollen
US-Justizminister Garland hat einen
unabhängigen Sonderermittler für die
Untersuchungen gegen exos-präsident
Trump ernannt der langjährige
Staatsanwalt Jack Smith soll die
Ermittlungen zu den Trumps Privatanwesen
gefundenen Geheimdokumenten übernehmen
außerdem soll er sich um Teile der
Untersuchung zum Sturm auf das Kapitol
am 6 Januar 2021 kümmern
in Essen hat ein Unbekannter mehrere
Schüsse auf das frühere rabbinerhaus der
Alten Synagoge abgegeben verletzt wurde
dabei laut Polizei niemand der
Staatsschutz leite die
Ermittlungskommission die Schüsse
durchschlugen offenbar in der Nacht eine
verglaste Eingangstür in dem Gebäude ist
ein Institut für deutsch-jüdische
Geschichte untergebracht
Nordrhein-Westfalens Innenminister Roll
sprach von einem Anschlag
in Iran sind erneut tausende Menschen
auf die Straße gegangen um den Sturz des
Regimes zu fordern und das trotz des
brutalen Vorgehens der Sicherheitskräfte
soll erneut mehrere Tote gegeben haben
südlich von Teheran diese Bilder
Demonstranten sollen das Geburtshaus von
aja toller Rumänien dem Gründer der
Islamischen Republik in Brand gesetzt
haben
der iranische Außenminister dem Westen
gestern vor gemeinsam mit Israel einen
Bürgerkrieg in Iran vorzubereiten
die einen gehen mutig auf die Straße die
anderen sehen keine Zukunft mehr für
sich in ihrer Heimat der Iran verliert
jedes Jahr viele junge meist gut
ausgebildete Frauen und Männer bei der
Abwanderung einer akademischen Elite
gehört das Land in die absolute
Weltspitze das Regime in Teheran steht
seit Wochen massiv unter Druck und
dennoch reicht der lange Arm der molars
immer noch weit auch bis nach Berlin wie
dieser Jan die zeigt
Iran fast täglich in Berlin doch auch
hier fühlen sich politisch aktive wie
Daniela seperi nicht sicher vor den
Spitzeln des iranischen Regimes
sie machen Fotos von uns machen Videos
von uns identifizieren uns und bringen
uns in Gefahr das ist der Grund warum
viele Menschen die einmal auf einer
regimekritischen Demonstration im
Ausland waren nie wieder in ihre anreihe
anreisen können weil sie damit rechnen
müssen am Flughafen raussortiert zu
werden erst kürzlich ein täglicher
Angriff auf dieses Protestcamp vor der
Grünen Parteizentrale Parham war dabei
als in der Nacht zwei Männer und zwei
verschleierte Frauen lautstark dieses
Schilder Abrissen erzählt er auf
Persisch
ich habe ihnen gesagt gib das Schild
zurück kurz darauf haben sie ein Messer
herausgeholt ich habe Angst bekommen und
bin schnell zu den anderen
zurückgelaufen ich sagte ruft die
Polizei die haben ein Messer
ein Tatverdächtiger wurde gefasst der
polizeiliche Staatsschutz ermittelt
einige Wochen zuvor war eine Mahnwache
vor der iranischen Botschaft betroffen
auch hier passierte es in der Nacht
bewaffnet seien sie gewesen hätten
persisch gesprochen drei Menschen kamen
verletzt ins Krankenhaus den Tätern
gelangen die Flucht der
Verfassungsschutz bestätigt die
Gefährdung iranischer Oppositioneller
nicht nur in ihrer Heimat sondern auch
hierzulande es gibt eine Gefährdung
jedenfalls bestimmter Personen in diesem
Umfeld wir wissen dass der Iran seit
vielen Jahren iranische Dienste die
Opposition auch hier in Deutschland
ausspähen das ist natürlich vom größten
Interesse ist wie iranische Dienste zu
sehen wer engagiert sich jetzt hier in
diesem Demonstrationsgeschehen man
bedroht natürlich auch indirekt indem
man meint wegen auf die Bedrohung von
Verwandten im Iran hinweist
verantwortlich dafür seinen Mitarbeiter
der iranischen Nachrichtendienste oder
auch regime-anhänger das Ziel
Oppositionelle auch im Ausland
einzuschüchtern das Regime weiß sehr
genau aufgrund der Erfahrung von 1979
mit der Revolution wo ja der
revolutionsführerin vom Ausland aus
agiert hat wie wichtig und wie
gefährlich
äh eine auslandsopposition sein kann und
auch die Studenten die im Ausland
operieren
trotz der Einschüchterungsversuche
Daniela seperi macht weiter sie sagt
viele die sich jahrelang nicht auf Demos
getraut haben sind jetzt dabei um
Gesicht zu zeigen für Freiheit in Iran
[Musik]
es ist ein echter Meilenstein die
ukrainische Armee hat nach Berechnungen
von Militärbeobachtern inzwischen über
die Hälfte des Territoriums
zurückerobert das Russland nach dem
Überfall am 24 Februar besetzt hatte wie
es jetzt weitergeht da sind sich die
Experten uneins Entscheidungsschlacht
abnutzungsgefechte alles möglich das
militärische Momentum ist auf Seiten der
Ukraine für die Menschen in den Dörfern
die jetzt eins nach dem anderen
zurückerobert wurden bleibt die Lage
hart oftmals ohne Wasser ohne Strom mit
dem Winter vor der Tür Henna Hebestreit
ist dort
hinter dem Gartenzaun begann das
Schlachtfeld 8 Monate lebten die
Einwohner von Brigitte zwischen den
Fronten das Dorf hat dabei einiges
abgekriegt er blieb hier mit 12 Nachbarn
bis zur Befreiung wir nennen in Oleg
seinen richtigen Namen sollen wir nicht
nennen auch sein Gesicht nicht zeigen
denn sein Sohn ist immer noch in der
Gewalt russischer Soldaten
augenzeugen haben Ihnen in einer
bestimmten Baracke des Lagers olenifka
gesehen mit einem Angriff auf das Lager
haben die Russen ihn irgendwo anders
hingebracht wir wissen aber nicht wo
seit dem Abzug der Russen aus Region und
Stadt razon gibt es viele solcher
Berichte über Menschen die verschwunden
sind oder misshandelt wurden diese
Polizeistation sollen die Russen für
verhörige genutzt haben
die Gefangenen dabei mit Kabeln
traktiert und ihnen Gasmasken aufgesetzt
um Ihnen die Luft zu nehmen
bei den Verhören haben sie ihren Opfer
auch die Hände hinter dem Rücken
gefesselt und mit Metallstangen verdreht
das ist alles unmenschlich
869 solcher Fälle aus der Region haben
die ukrainischen Ermittler bislang
zusammengetragen nur von knapp 500
Personen wissen sie dass sie
freigelassen wurden einer von ihnen ist
Maxim
haben sie einen spezielles Gerät
gebracht damit haben sie Ohren und
Genitalien mit Stromschlägen traktiert
rund um die Uhr konnte man die Schreie
aus den Zellen hören
in der Umgebung von tresonne erinnert
noch vieles an die schwere Zeit bis zum
Ende der russischen Besatzung dieser
munitions-transport hat die Front nie
erreicht viele Soldaten die ihn
begleiteten hatten keine Chance ganz in
der Nähe von Brigitte wo sie ebenfalls
von Toten berichten
Angriff los ging wollte unsere Nachbarin
Tanja rosetzka ihre Kühe von der Weide
holen eine Granate ist direkt neben ihr
detoniert hinterher sammelten wir ein
was von ihr übrig war und haben Tanja
begraben
im ganzen Dorf gibt es wieder Strom noch
Gas Katharina und ihr Ehemann Gregory
kämpfen gegen die feuchte Kälte nur mit
ihrem kleinen alten Ofen
ein paar häuserweite überlegt sich dem
ukrainischen Militär anzuschließen ein
Sturmgewehr erfahren wir hat er schon
angeblich gefunden auf dem Schlachtfeld
hinter dem Gartenzaun
passt vom Energieversorger das bedeutet
aktuell in vielen Fällen jetzt gibt es
sie schwarz auf weiß die Preiserhöhung
sowohl beim Gas als auch beim Strom
drehen viele Anbieter momentan an der
Preisschraube für Entlastung sollen die
dezemberhilfen Sorgen und Stefanie
Barrett so langsam wird auch konkreter
wie die Erstattung genau ablaufen soll
ja aber tatsächlich drängt auch die Zeit
denn heute in zwei Wochen schon muss die
staatliche Erstattung des Dezember
Abschlags bereits bei den Gasversorgern
auf dem Konto sein sonst können sie
wiederum nicht auf die Abschlagszahlung
der Kunden verzichten aus Kreisen der
Stadtwerke heißt es schon selbst eine
Zahlungsverzögerung von einer Woche
würde etliche Versorger nicht überstehen
die Energieunternehmen sollen
unbürokratisch über die bundeseigene KfW
Bank entschädigt werden dazu müssen aber
vorher die Anträge geprüft werden ab
kommenden Montag nun sollen die 1.500
Gasversorger wiederum uns Kunden über
die Erstattung des Dezember Abschlags
informieren all das auf jeden Fall eine
ziemlich sportliche Herausforderung und
viele Fragezeichen gibt es auch
weiterhin beim gaspreisdeckel oder so
ist es das Gesetz zur gaspreisbremse
sollte ja heute eigentlich im
Bundeskabinett beraten werden ist aber
noch mals vertagt worden ab März soll ja
der Gaspreis für private Verbraucher und
kleine und mittlere Firmen gedeckelt
werden 80% des vorjahresverbrauchs soll
es dann preiswerter geben für den Rest
müssen weiterhin die hohen Marktpreise
für Gas gezahlt werden es soll aber nach
Angaben von Bundeswirtschaftsminister
Harbeck ein unkompliziertes Modell
werden die Preise würden dann
automatisch von den Versorgern abgesenkt
bei Mietern werden die Entlassungen aber
ohnehin frühestens im Sommer mit der
Nebenkostenabrechnung ankommen vielen
Dank Stefanie für deine Einschätzung
zur WM in Katar da gab es heute gab
heute der Deutsche Fußball-Bund seine
auftaktpressekonferenz DFB-Präsidenten
Neuendorf äußerte sich dabei erneut
kritisch gegenüber dem Weltverband FIFA
und dessen Präsident Infantino anders
als Infantino gefordert hatte wolle sich
das deutsche Team vorbehalten mit
politischen Botschaften für
Menschenrechte und Meinungsfreiheit zu
werden eine Entscheidung in Katha sorgte
heute noch für Aufsehen die Behörde des
gastgeberlands entschied das ist anders
als geplanten nun doch keinen
alkoholhaltiges Bier in Stadien geben
wird
ja noch bevor sie überhaupt angefangen
hat entwickelt sich die WM zum Albtraum
für den Großsponsor eine amerikanische
mammutbrauerei auf dem Fanfest
allerdings soll weiter richtiges Bier zu
haben sein der halbe Liter für über 13
Euro
und mehr dazu später auch in unserem
heute journal Update mit Bericht und
einem Interview gegen 0.20 mit
Christopher Wehrmann wir freuen uns
morgen wieder auf sie irgendwann nach
wetten dass für heute danke fürs
zuschauen tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die
Luftmassengrenze über Deutschland
existiert immer noch das bedeutet nach
Nordosten ist die Luft kälter als im
Südwesten und genau wo sich diese
Luftmassen Treffen gibt es Schnee aber
dieser Schnee kommt nicht besonders weit
voran sie sehen es hier also ein wenig
weiter südlich liegt es dann morgen
Abend und auch an der Ostsee gibt es
Schneeregen und auch Graupel Gewitter in
der Nacht also Richtung Ostsee Regen und
auch Schnee und da wo es schraffiert ist
genauso in der Mitte da wird es glatte
auf den Straßen durch Schnee und
Schneematsch aber nicht nur denn es gibt
auch überfrierende Nässe es wird kalt
Temperaturen gehen zurück bis auf -7
Grad nach Nordosten hin und sechs Grad
im Südwesten Deutschlands das ist die
Temperatur Spanne der nachts morgen dann
weiterer Schnee der sich allmählich
weiter nach Süden durchsetzt ganz
Richtung Nordosten an der Ostsee gibt es
auch Regen und Schnee und eben auch
durchaus graupelgewitter ja und wieder
in dem schraffierten Bereich da kann es
glatt werden ansonsten nach Norden hin
da lockert es auf und es gibt viel
Sonnenschein Richtung norddeutsche Tiefe
Ebene oder Richtung Niederlausitz ja und
die Temperaturen dazu 10 Grad im
Südwesten ansonsten aber durchaus nach
Osten den Dauerfrost mit 0 bis -2 Grad
und die nächsten Tage noch mal Schnee
durchaus am Sonntag z.B nach Nordwesten
in wobei der Nordosten deutlich kälter
als bei 0 bis 10 Grad und danach gibt's
durchaus Schauer aber nicht mehr so
viele
und damit ein schöner Abend